Last time I was in Pittsburgh.
Well,
the first time rather I said,
well not even the first time.
One of the Times I was in Pittsburgh,
I was there for a furry convention.
Oh,
I was there for UFC and the UFC was in Pittsburgh at the same time a furry
convention was on.
That's when I found out about furries.
I had a nice long conversation with the dudes who work behind the desk at the
hotel where they were telling me the firies were asking for their food in bowls
so they can eat off the ground.
No.
Yeah,
they were all furries except us like a fuck is going on.
Went with me.
I forget who opened for me and my have been Duncan,
but um,
the,
they were asking for a litter box so they could shit and piss in a box.
I want to do that.
No you don't.
No,
I don't.
Just for a laugh.
How are you going to wipe?
Where are you going to do to finish?
Well,
it's like grown men who want to be a,
they want to wear diapers and have somebody spank them and change them.
And,
well,
here's what's interesting and there's a lot of people that think that,
look,
I am 100% in support of people being trans.
Don't get me wrong if you want,
I'm in sport.
I'm just bored of you being whenever you want to being.
Um,
I'm a person who believes in free will or your,
your ability to freely express yourself,
I should say.
But if you work for a corporation,
you work for a Tech Corporation,
especially a particularly Progressive Tech Corporation.
You run into some real problems.
And I was talking to a guy who was telling me the,
you don't know the half of it,
that we're dealing with a guy who,
uh,
he identifies as an animal and that he,
he believes that he's kin,
like he's a fox can or a dog cat or something like that and he wants a litter
box in his office.
This guy wants to be able to shat in his fucking office into a,
a box of now.
I appreciate that.
Now I want to say this about him and I'm not a psychiatrist and I have no right
to really diagnose,
but he's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
he is crazy.
But here's the thing,
like you're letting people be crazy correctly when you're letting a six foot
four man compete in women's weightlifting because he's decided that he's a woman
now and now he's winning and he's wearing makeup and he looks like a gorilla and
he's onstage lifting his arms up.
Yay.
Diversity.
You're,
you're stealing from women's stealing.
You're stealing,
cheating,
you're cheating.
You're fucking 100% cheating.
And then anybody says or not,
you're an asshole,
you're an asshole.
But you know,
this is about humanness.
And when,
when,
when someone's feelings,
how they identify in that moment,
which of course are so transitory,
right?
I mean I'm,
I the whole my fucking,
not to bring it back,
but the whole idea of complicated apes is,
was your,
your new specialists and it's available basically everywhere.
Right?
You could get it on iTunes.
He will have it.
It does.
Oh my God,
this crew and wherever the fuck look under here,
if I look in your sock drawer,
there's my Spanish stocked on the side.
That's amazing.
But,
but,
but I,
but I do think that,
you know,
we are complicated like were were bipolar apes,
sinners and saints and everything in between.
I'm not so it your feelings how you feel.
Sometimes I feel like an asshole and other times I feel like a saint and
everything in between you,
you know,
it's very difficult to,
say well this is your a noun,
which means you're this as opposed to sort of a verb,
which is I'm always changing.
And that,
that to me is the problem with when you identify,
when you,
when you emotionally identify with something,
well for now you do for now that that's what's important to you.
But I can't,
I can't tailor my life and my entire corporation,
this is what the part of the problem is and this is what you just hit on.
Part of the problem is these people want to be special for no reason at all.
Correct.
And so to be special for no reason at all.
One of the best ways is to do a Bruce Jenner.
Did he become Caitlyn Jenner?
And then he special?
That guy was a fucking loser even though he was a gigantic superstar in the
Olympics 40 years ago.
But from then on,
they shat on that guy every fucking show.
That's right.
They shit on him.
He was the buffoon of that show.
And then all of a sudden he becomes a woman ever is like,
you're amazing.
And we'll maybe go woman of the year and a woman for six months.
All the women that do things like Christina [inaudible] came up with Christa
because CRISPR cas nine and all those,
Oh,
is this the guy?
Okay,
this is hilarious.
This is a dude who's a comic,
is the comics of browser rapper.
He's a rapper and he's fucking jacked.
So he decided to identify as a woman wanted me to.
So it destroys the British women's deadlift record without even trying.
Wow.
Ps identified as a woman whilst lifting weights don't be a bigot.
I love it.
He's so jacked.
Imagine that.
So two biological men don't have any physical strength advantage over women in
2019 okay.
Anybody says that is a fool.
That's,
that's foolish.
There's a reason why it,
yeah.
Good for him.
What's his name?
Zuby.
Zuby is his stage name.
Shout out to Zubin Oxford graduate.
It doesn't that mean you're a Rhode Scholar?
Zubie congratulations to you,
sir.
I'm following you right now.
I'm going to go right to my goddamn Twitter for all the shirt free.
Thank God.
Bless you.
Look,
it's like this is silliness for six and here's the problem with a lot of these
progressive's is that they're really nice people.
That's what it is.
Be follows me,
and now I follow him.
Shout out to Zubin.
They're nice people as long as you have to with them.
Yes,
exactly.
If you don't,
they try to DDI platform.
You.